even today as an entrepreneur when you
build a business you've got to do the
simple things over and over and over and
it's
it is in the application of the that is
in the iteration and application that
excellence has achieved
the hardest thing to do is to is to
enable people to see themselves as they
are
i often talk about we don't close here
so we don't close a sale we open a
relationship
need motivation what the top 10 we
believe national
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
busy tembeo and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one choose progress
over emotions your reality is your
reality
you're not imagining it you're not
imagining that you're poor you're not
imagining that you're left out because
you live in a third world country
you're not imagining that you're not
getting the right quality of education
to make you globally competitive you're
not imagining that that's
real right okay but now that you've got
it
you can live in the emotion and
sometimes i do i get really really mad
and really really upset
but then the following morning comes and
you realize that you've moved
not an inch of distance yet you've
expanded all of this time and this
emotion
i mean right now if you think about the
world we live in just think about how
much hatred there is
think about how much anger there is and
yet we're not
moving so i what really pulls me out of
it and it's an honest conversation with
me is i go
do you want the emotion or do you want
progress because you can't have both
oh sh right go go deeper on that that's
crazy just gave me the chills
i'll give you an example you're at the
gym right
you're curling your rep 8 and your body
starts to fire off those signals in your
brain and it goes
stop it hurts if you stop
you get the emotion you don't get the
progress
so if you talk to any decent athlete
they'll tell you that where the pain
stop
starts is when the work starts right
talk to any decent entrepreneur that's
built a large-scale business they'll
tell you
that they had to go through so you
either get the emotion
or you get the progress but you can't
have both right
we're living in this world today where
everybody is just so
deeply embedded in the emotion i want to
be angry at tom because he's
x y and z and i want to be angry at
varsity because yeah
yet you make no progress rule number two
hone your communication skills
i say this to every person i meet which
is public speaking is a skill it's a
tool
and it is in my view the single most
important skill
of any person who sees themselves as a
leader in the new age
the the ability to communicate or the
lack of it
often determines the extent to which you
will succeed in life so when you're
going into an interview it's about
whether or not you can sell yourself
persuasion exactly right it's all like
ceos spend 90
of their time persuading people to do
things precisely yeah and so
your ability to communicate to speak in
public
as a result of it often will determine
how society perceives you
and how successful you'll become at
whatever pursuit you do
rule number three create relationships
when we do and i do a fair amount of
sales training on my own team here but
i often talk about we don't close here
so we don't close a sale we open a
relationship
the way we lead the sales process is the
whole time
we're having a conversation with you to
give you a sense of why you would
benefit by having a relationship with us
this has nothing to do with whether or
not you buy from us this is just like
we want to have a relationship with you
and we have that relationship by
offering these
products which we believe suit this need
of yours and by the way it's connected
to the things you find important if
these are the things you find important
because we do
then we should sustain this relationship
for a period of time and we do that by
having you sign this contract
so we really you know and i've taken a
lot of time to i've spent a lot of time
with my sales team going
don't close a sale people should never
feel like you've closed anything
they should rather feel like they've
become part of something part of a
family part of a movement
part of something that matters something
that's going to make a difference right
especially today's world with
millennials you know who don't buy
stuff based on on value they buy stuff
based on values
so what you really want to make sure is
that you open the sale
i think public speaking taught me that
kind of instinctively because in public
speaking what you're doing
is you're communicating a very complex
set of ideas as simply as possible
and you're doing it in the hope that
people are that it's going to inspire
action
so you know when martin luther king said
i have a dream that one day the sons of
former slaves and the sons of former
slave owners
will be able to break bread on the table
of brotherhood the first thing he did is
he used imagery because the minute the
mind can see it
then then you're closer to doing it
right but the second thing he does it
says i have a dream
towards the end of the speech if you
listen to it he says we need a messaging
to the united states that says that you
guys
have issued us this check for the
promises you've made but this check has
returned saying no money in the bank
account
so he says even though i have this dream
if the
system of the situation doesn't allow
the stream to be actualized it's not
going to be actualized and um
and that works that's really really an
effective way of doing it so i would say
to anybody who's in
a sales process particularly people who
are entrepreneurs if you're an
entrepreneur you're selling every day
is you don't close a sale you open a
relationship and you open a relationship
in the same way you would when you want
to date someone by going
i like you i think we have a bit of
chemistry i think this thing could go
somewhere
but i think so what do you say about a
date then at the end of the first day to
go what do you say about a second one
right that's kind of in our firm that's
kind of how we think about building
relationships with clients it's just
you you see the world in this way we see
the world in this way
what do you say we go on a date let's
try something together
um and that opening of relationships is
far more sustainable because
by the way just one final thing every
time you close a sale notice what you
have to do
is you have to make a hard promise you
never have to
you never close a sale without making a
hard promise so before you close the
sale you go through the promising state
where you go
i promise my product or my business is
going to do
one two three four five when you open a
relationship you don't
really make a promise you make a
commitment
you kind of go i commit that i'm gonna
be available that i'm gonna do the best
i can
that i wanna make sure that i'm gonna do
the best i can to make sure that we
succeed
but a commitment is different because
the promise is final and commitment
allows for latitude
so in a commitment where you fail you
can be honest and go
i thought it would but it didn't work or
there's a problem here it's a mechanical
issue
and because you've opened a relationship
people are a lot more forgiving
than if you made very hard promises
trying to close a sale
and now this thing doesn't do what you
said it would do six months in rule
number four
understand the meaning of a brand i say
this to my team all the time which is
even in the construct of brands we must
always recognize that we will never
be the equal of the brand and that's
what many people who build brands get
wrong
so particularly people who do personal
branding so they go well
i'm a great ex i'm a great comedian a
great singer a great actress a great
whatever so you become this brand thing
but you forget that a brand is something
that lives in people's mind which is
which is to say your existence becomes a
manifestation of somebody else's
expectation
now most people are bad at the
expectation part so they think you're
still in charge you're not in charge
anymore
this thing called the brand now outlives
you like
it's a bit like building a lego set you
just built the pieces what people will
do with this lego set is up to you and
that's
kind of how i think about my life that
is such a hard truth it is right it is
such a hard truth
and by the way the most powerful brands
are the ones
that the people who construct don't own
when you
cease ownership that's when you've built
a brand caches
exactly because it means that there's
somebody on the other end who's gone
this thing is so powerful not only do i
want to be a part of it
i want to help build it mm-hmm that's
that's that's hard i imagine you're a
lot like me like i'm a
yeah what are we doing nowadays and also
you still want because it's annelie you
still want analogy making the decisions
right
so basically you are teaching us that to
when when you know that you can
comfortably start releasing the power
let go that's when you know that you've
been successful
true there is a i think it was frederick
nietzsche that said the true prop
true power finds expression yeah in the
absence of power
which is to say when i can give power
away and still have power
i have power also if you want to have
more self belief and more self
confidence i've created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below the very
first thing i do when i wake up in the
morning is i want to get my head right i
do this thing called priming
you have to go build self-confidence
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected rule number
five do whatever it takes
i live by two core principles right the
first is that
everything everyone knows they learned
and i don't accept that i'm less
intelligent than the next person which
means i can learn it too
right the second is that every single
excuse i have
is valid but that's still not going to
give me the results that i want
and so we do live in this really uh
pc culture today um um
where people are looking for the excuse
and the truth is the excuse is
completely valid
yes you are a young black person growing
up in democratic south africa for the
past 26 years but for
hundreds of years before that it wasn't
built for you to succeed
right yes you're living in one of the
most difficult credit capital markets in
the world so it's hard to get access to
funding to start a business
yeah all of that stuff's true but that's
still not going to change the
circumstance
so so the test is not whether or not you
know the
the reasons for not succeeding the test
is whether or not you're willing to do
whatever it takes
to get to that next level and a big part
of the whatever it takes actually is
just remain teachable
just just be a student student of the
game a student of life a student of
those who've achieved
and i found that those two things have
really stood me in good stead rule
number six
have consistent discipline so i did
martial arts i did music i played the
violin etc
but everything else i did is as a result
of the martial arts of course he plays
the violin
of course he plays the violin because
yeah i mean you know the idea that
you've got to do your qatar over and
over and over and over and over
same movement same rotation when even
today as an entrepreneur when you build
a business you've got to do the simple
things
over and over and over and it's it is in
the application of the
it is in the iteration and application
that excellence has achieved
and i think that's what people don't
understand so people go how do you get
to number one of the thing
you actually just have to do the simple
things but do them every day religiously
and each time with a consistent
discipline that's that's the mark that's
how you get there
rule number seven understand the
mechanics of selling
i think the mistake many of us make when
we're trying to close the sale is we act
like sales people
right so so you know there's something
counterintuitive about
sales training which is you learn
everything you learn in sales so that
you can do it instinctively and
intuitively rather than do it of a
script
so if you come across to a client if
you're doing something
for a script they immediately feel as if
being sold to and just like you do when
you're watching a tv ad you get up and
go make popcorn
because nobody wants to be sold to as
human beings we've built up such a high
emotional resistance to being sold stuff
because we're
being sold every day you're on your ig
and this pop-up swans of ads you're on
facebook in the sponsored ads you're
driving on the highway and there's a
billboard you just
you know if you get to your emails and
you're filled up with spam somebody's
always trying to sell you something so
as human beings are built up such an
emotional resistance and a cognitive
resistance to selling
that the best way to sell is not to the
best way to start let's understand the
mechanics of selling
understand how it actually works but
then do it in a way that is just
uh instinctive and intuitive for you and
the only way to do that is to through
practice
rule number eight make decisions perfect
i have come to realize that there are no
perfect decisions but decisions that i
make perfect
that is something else that i loved
reading in your book yeah walk me
through that
garden again right it's you so remember
you're in this journey you're doing this
thing called life
you're building this thing called a
business you're in pursuit of this
this end goal called profit and
somewhere in between it the pursuit of
purpose you're trying to create a
better workplace for your people a place
where they can come and belong you want
to serve communities you want to better
the lives of customers
there are a thousand things you want to
do and so we go to business schools and
business schools particularly the ones i
went to
teach you about they give you case
studies and go this business leader did
x and that business leader did x and
there's like this literature that says
they make perfect decisions then when i
spend time with business leaders i
realize they don't
most of them just make a decision yeah
and they're comfortable in the knowledge
that decisions
are matter by their nature which is to
say i want to get on the freeway and
just go from one place i'm going to
another
yeah in my head i kind of have a path of
how i'm going to get there
but if on the way there's traffic i'm
going to change the route if i had a
pothole i'll stop and fix
but i'm going there but i'm going to get
this and this is the thing about the
perfect decision rather than the
decision made perfect
the decision made perfect builds into it
the assumption and the knowledge that
i'm going to get things wrong
and i'm comfortable with getting things
wrong because it's when you think you
have to make perfect decisions that you
get into the most dangerous thing
leaders do
ego bravado knowledge arrogance just
walk in and like i own it no you don't
but we've always done it this way
no no like you're a part of a process
you're a servant
sit down rule number nine acknowledge
your reality
the hardest thing to do is to is to
enable people to see themselves as they
are
not as they hoped they were not as
they've been taught they are
but as they actually are it's the single
hardest thing to do and i'll tell you
why
because we're all embedded in this
construct of a thing called
identity right and so and what people
forget is identity by its very nature
one is
man-made and two is exclusive what that
means is
the minute i say i'm male it means i'm
not female if i say i'm black it means
i'm not white
if i say i'm african it means i'm not
american if i say i am
you know educated it means i'm not
illiterate so all the little words we
use to construct identity
put us in a box they don't free us right
and it's something people i think don't
think about because people today have
assumed an identity for who they are and
it's it's all over right it's in the
media it's on social media it's on tv
it's in the newspapers it's
in in music videos all you're being sold
is an identity this is what
you should be based on where you come
from
and based on how you've been socialized
very early on my father taught me that i
didn't have to be
what society told me right that i could
be different if i want
to i want to put that in context and see
if i'm understanding what you're saying
so
um i read nelson mandela's long walk to
freedom it
with me dude that book is so good
like when every second i think i'm a
badass and then i remember
that the man faced 27 years in prison
and refuse to compromise his principles
i'm just not that hardcore
and yeah like so that that is phenomenal
and i remember him saying in the book he
was like
this this is nelson mandela talking he
said i got on an airplane and the pilot
was black and for a minute i was scared
because i didn't think black people
could fly a plane and he was like what
the [ __ ]
like how do i think that and he said if
that had seeped into my mind
identity right then how many other
people had accepted something less than
who they were because
of what society had told them is that
what you mean that we're sort of subtly
taking on these i can't i can't i can't
exactly so um here's a great example
i'm short therefore i can't model okay i
mean
it's not it's not established that short
people should model
but whether you should or whether you
can are very different tests
right um and by the way i approach
every little thing in my life like that
like if all the [ __ ] i do
i go i shouldn't but it doesn't mean i
can't there's a big
difference so if you're telling me i
shouldn't be in the room you may be
correct
it doesn't mean i don't have the
capacity to be in the room i want to
force my way in
and i'm going to get to change your mind
so this thing about identity
i think is so powerful because in
today's world where we've
you know we're no longer demographics
we're a psychographic now
there is a kid living in kuala lumpur
who's never been out of kuala lumpur
who sounds like a kid in brooklyn new
york because he's watching jay-z
on on youtube but he so he's completely
immersed in that culture and he's never
left his small little village
right and that's exactly the point is
everything you've been taught you are
somebody taught you that's what you are
now
you can keep that identity but again you
can't get the progress
and so what a lot of people do is they
hang on to it right in south africa
it um it's often about gender sometimes
it's about tribe right so what tribe you
come from
there's a big generation issue so it's
i'm part of it this generation
yeah all those things are true but
do you want the identity or do you want
the progress
because you can't have both um i'll tell
you just quickly a story so my dad was
the
sensei in the dojo right and i used to
train with my dad in the dojo
and so i asked him one time i was like
how come we get to change belts like
i mean couldn't you teach the
methodology without the belt system
he said two things he said first human
beings are incentive based so you need
something to aim for
but he said the second thing is the
reason we give you a belt is because it
assigns an identity
now it doesn't mean that if your orange
belt you can't take on a brown belt
it's just you embed that in your mind
and you go well he's seen you then
therefore
and so one of the things he said to me
one of the things you're going to have
to learn
is that real life doesn't have a belt
system so everything we know and i've
learned about identity
is given to us it's a it's a template
that somebody has given you
and you can just choose to run that
script of macros or not
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is don't look for a template for life
the older i've gotten
and the more experience i've received or
the more experience i've had rather
and the more guidance i've received from
people that i look up to
people are called mirrors of mine
of the things i've learned is that there
is no template for life
and so you know there's this idea that
there are certain
uh truths that are so universal that
they are
um that they are without nuance
um and that's not true um
every every bit of truth has a nuance to
it
so the reason i'm saying that is is
because i i've become fairly reticent
when people ask me the questions so
and somebody actually asked me the
question yesterday young entrepreneur
was like
i've got these four businesses should i
do what everybody says which is like
dump three and focus on one
or should i keep all four going and i
ended up saying
what i'll say to you which is i actually
don't know because i think our parts are
different
and i think our parts find manifestation
in ways that are different
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 chance of
following through
that's what we do here believe nation we
get motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances even further of following
through
so what was your biggest takeaway from
this video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you my mother has the most amazing and
uncanny ability
to decipher what matters from what
doesn't very quickly
and then she would go through this thing
where she would iteratively tell you all
the time
this is what's important this is what's
not this is what's important this is
what's not
so sooner or later you begin to know how
to do it yourself
uh do you know what i mean uh it becomes
like you know your own second your
default settings
exactly yeah exactly you know like um
i've got soccer boots i don't have shin
guards
didn't you say that
like go go do this thing right and it's
um i i
it's just been it's it's been a big
lesson for me that i've learned from
omar which is
just decipher what matters from what
doesn't and focus on what matters
because
sooner or later society will forget the
other stuff it moves on
it's trends anyway and and it'll pass
and then you'll live the life you've
wanted to live invariably
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there